[Música]
Si tuviera que clasificarse frente a los
demás en función de un rasgo específico
que diría sobre cómo los ves y cómo te
ven a ti reunimos a cinco cantantes y
les pedimos que se clasificaran en
función de su talento para el canto
percibido luego los reorganizamos en
función de los votos de nuestra
audiencia Esta es la clasificación Hola
Mi nombre es Laila tengo 19 años y soy
cantautora de más de cinco años y soy de
redlands California Hola Mi nombre es
Edmond soy de China Hill California no
soy cantante profesional solo lo hago
por diversión en el auto o en el karaoke
Soy Richard soy de Columbus Georgia y
hago música bajo el nombre de simply
Rich soy cantante rapero y productor de
días Soy ingeniero de software Hola Soy
Dani me encanta cantar tengo 33 años y
canto desde que estaba no sé recién
salido del vientre
Hola soy Roxana y mi pasión y mis sueños
siempre ha sido desde niña ser como
Hannah Montana pero estoy tratando de
averiguar cómo hacerlo ahora como adulta
bajo el nombre de Osi cantarán un solo
para mostrar su talento O sí
expectations
[Música]
Avicii Wake Me Up
vaya muy bien
[Música]
o impresionante
veo después
[Música]
Gracias bien
excelente están clasificar entre ellos
Quién es el mejor cantante
decirlo para que no sea como eres el
menos más como tal vez por experiencia
podría ser mayor así que cierto y por
mucho no tengo experiencia profesional
en esto así que abriré camino hacia
abajo estoy bien con eso
voy a ir aquí de acuerdo siento que con
la música hay una forma objetiva de
clasificar pero también hay una manera
más subjetiva cómo te hace sentir esto
algo más emocional Entonces cuál te
gustaría más
sentí cosas contigo
así que creo que tú y yo deberíamos
cambiar porque siento que sí
no sé solo técnica y saber ese tipo de
cosas sientes que eso contribuye a estar
en un buen nivel de habilidades saber
hacer falsete o saber armonías y cosas
así siento que sí porque se trata de
clasificar cantantes sino artistas o
cantautores cierto En definitiva creo
que un gran cantante evoca esa emoción y
hace sentir algo entonces a pesar de que
la técnica realmente tiene peso creo que
eso es muy importante sí puede que me
esté basando en eso buena forma de la
secundaria estaba en el coro teatro
musical eres como un coro de secundaria
y bajo dependiendo
sin esfuerzo sí Ese es mi truco la
habilidad de armonizar Sí esa es una
habilidad en sí misma puede que me
arrepienta pero quieren intentar
armonizar justo
o algo así
Oh Dios mío
[Música]
podemos hacer una banda Claro que sí
Bueno sonamos muy bien juntos pero se
supone que nos tenemos muy bien estoy de
acuerdo con el nivel en el que canto
pero ustedes tienen más experiencia y
pueden tocar instrumentos y seguirlos de
manera semiprofesional saben es difícil
de saber porque de manera similar
comencé a cantar cuando era muy joven
pero cantar bien eso no llegó hasta
después esas fueron lecciones de voz
tocar más instrumentos y aprender a
estar con otros músicos quiero ser como
Prince y tocar al menos 28 instrumentos
puedes escuchar la musicalidad en tu voz
después de la universidad tuve un poco
de crisis existencial porque no sabía lo
que quería hacer sé que no quería estar
en la ruina así que me concentré en la
ingeniería de software mi hermano me
convenció para que comenzara a hacer mi
propia música y me ha curado junto con
el diario y la terapia música para lo
mismo todas mis canciones tienen que ver
con Salud Mental Así que te entiendo
alguien no está conforme con lo que
plantean y Quiere cantar quiero mostrar
un lado diferente
[Música]
Sí eso fue muy linda
cuando cumplías las vocales me gustas
ahí y se oye angelical Ok humilde
fanfarronería pero he oído angelical
antes Gracias
bien alguien está descontento con su
lugar soy competitivo así que quiero ser
el primero pero
digo él cantó algo más puedo cantar otra
cosa
[Música]
[Aplausos]
mejor quédate ahí
sí mejor quédate cómo nos sentimos me
siento contenta genuinamente ustedes son
geniales y también ustedes
emocionalmente sí creo que todos podemos
estar de acuerdo de que realmente
en primer lugar Laila quiero que cambie
con él
haré que cambies con goxana
ahora estoy nervioso oxana haré que
cambies con Dani Adiós
Y por último pero no menos importante
oxana haré que cambies una vez más con
Richard
y estos son los resultados de la
audiencia me siento como el emoji
no esperaba eso en absoluto porque sí
creo que siempre hay algo de lo que
puedes aprender como artistas sé que
todavía tengo mucho por recorrer creo
que todos aportaron su sonido tono y
estilo únicos me sorprende sobre todo
mentir también me sorprendo no tal vez
fueron las canciones que eligió de
verdad me agradó su voz Supongo que
necesito más variedad y alcance Ojalá
hubiera venido a mostrar un poco más
pero creo que lo más hermoso de la
música es que el arte están un subjetivo
y a veces no resuena como nadie y eso es
la belleza de esto porque a veces lo
hará mientras Richard desde delante de
mí las cosas estarán bien nunca hubiera
puesto la clasificación de esta manera
pero es un honor haber ganado la dureza
sí La pureza de eso de los cinco ella
era el sonido más original es como ojo
es algo nuevo es algo sí se sentía
fresco fue muy divertido
vamos todos al karaoke
el coro Siempre será uno de los momentos
más geniales que experimentado hacemos
una ola
bueno Hagamos una ola dijiste Hola Así
que vamos hagámoslo yo empiezo